i know
i know you can't say yes or not but your
world is not like hey let's take the
proper route and you know let's
you have to make their life a living
kill by playing some of their games
against them no
so not so much playing their games
against them um
you know everything that we do is
reviewed by legal counsel
um we work with prosecutors love us and
we wouldn't be able to
we wouldn't be able to do the things
that we did if our if the
work that we put together was not
admissible in court
all right and and everything that we do
is admissible in court we're open to
discovery
it's uh it's a very very above
board operation but what we do is we
infiltrate their communications
uh and i hope there are human
traffickers out there right now
listening to that
and wondering whether or not that person
they're communicating with online is
actually one of my intelligence analysts
uh we infiltrate their communications
where their they're they're sharing best
practices
they're um they're they literally will
will coordinate with each other to say
hey you know the super bowl is coming to
my town
um i've only got three girls i need i
need other guys to come down and bring
more girls so that we can service what
is a market opportunity for them
and that's a a key differentiator in the
way that we fight human trafficking is
we fight it as a market we fight it
through economics
where in your business and in my other
business i'm always trying to
reduce risk right we're always trying to
mitigate it
what our whole what we do at deliver
fund is we
increase market risk for the human
traffickers to cut into their profit
margins and make it harder for them to
do business
yeah but human traffickers kind of like
obviously
you'll see where i'm going with this uh
nick only seven percent of people are
going to graduate
prairie rescue watch me do it only one
person is going to become a cia watch me
do it
86 which is only 14 of people that do
what you're doing right now
their marriage ends up at a divorce oh
if i beat seven percent and one percent
i'm going to beat 14
that's not a problem i got it right are
these guys intimidated by that they're
like dude you're not going to catch me
we know what we're doing we're smarter
than you they're thinking they're going
to outsmart you every single time
because no and and here's here's the
mystery you know what i'm saying right
you know what i know
absolutely but here's a misconception
about human trafficking right people
will say that human trafficking is the
largest growing criminal enterprise
it's just not true narcotics and guns
especially with all the wars going on
around the world
narcotics and guns are you know illegal
gun running is
hands down the largest illicit
commodities the next
is people will say well you can actually
make more money
from uh you know from selling human
trafficking victims
than you can from narcotics or guns that
is also not true
because you can have a shipping
container full of cocaine or aks
sitting in a port somewhere and you can
leave it there for two years
and those the drugs and the guns are
worth just as much as they were
when you put that container there you
can't do that with people
right people have people require
overhead
you have to house them you have to feed
them you have to keep them in at least
good enough conditions so that customers
want to spend some time with them
and that's that's that's the achilles
heel that cuts into the profit margins
of of human traffickers and so most of
your smart criminals i mean your
your people who would be curing cancer
were they not criminals
most of them are into some type of
organized crime
around either narcotics or guns or
you know ripping off banks credit card
fraud those types of things
it's actually uh in a there are
exceptions to this rule but
it's it's not your smartest criminals
who are human traffickers
there's also a piece here you know i saw
in doing research that you you've
interviewed many members of
of the mob my guess is if you go ask
them what they think about human
trafficking
they're gonna say that's over the line
and if we found somebody doing that in
our organization
they were gonna end up in a box um and
that's what happens with a lot of these
these criminal enterprises too
is uh you know you'll have you'll have
uh
you know narcotics criminal enterprises
who aren't aren't going to allow their
people
to start harming children so so even
within the criminal
underworld there's there's an ethic line
when it comes to
children that people won't cross oh
there's no question about it uh and they
even had a code the la cosa noiser they
wouldn't touch drugs although
several people did but that was part of
their code as well uh
so not the smartest criminals okay so
not the smartest criminals
meaning they're not trying to play the
oh i'm gonna beat the odds of seven
percent one percent fourteen percent so
you're saying they're scared like if you
scare them they run away like a little
cat is it are they
are they scared criminals like can you
scare them away from the industry or no
no not really okay so so this is all
they know
okay so business model to catch them
i'm just i'm not in your world but i'm
just thinking about it so
if it's super bowl and these are the
girls that are doing it you know they're
coming in and hey customers
go people gonna they're gonna go online
to get somebody hey i'd want too many
drinks i only call somebody how do i
find somebody hey we got
so it's the business model to go to the
super bowl
and go find those sites and call 100 200
300 400 of them
then you send your guys to go
meet with the girls and then you tell
the girls
that you're willing to help them out and
interrogate them to get a feel if they
are working with somebody
and then you have them come with you you
can't get all 300 of them because
they're scared for their lives that that
you know individuals it's the
relationship with the pimp and the
prostitute and
you don't have that relationship it's
fear based absolutely then
you convince a percentage to go with you
and then you backtrack giving them
protection and safety
and then through backtracking you find
out who it is
and then you go track them down but at
that point they know that you've taken
some of their people so they're probably
on the run
is that part of the business model at
least not yours because you're not the
one that does that you just give intel
is that one part of the business model
that the law enforcement does or no
yeah so that's that's exactly what law
enforcement does uh law enforcement
you know gets in front of the girls uh
because you got it you gotta have a
witness
right you gotta you gotta have you gotta
have proof uh gets in front of them and
says hey
you know and usually a lot of times
using our intel here's what we know
about you
we know that you you and that girl over
there are actually all connected and we
know that you're run by this guy
we know that he's sitting in a car in
the parking lot um all we need you to do
is
is tell us that he's holding you against
your will
and uh and we got this or in many many
cases
what what can happen is uh you know the
human trafficker is controlling the girl
so he'll go drop her off at whatever
venue
and as as uh as he's dropping her off
law enforcement swoops
in and uh and catches them together so
so you you do have those types of cases
but some of these are very very
insidious we had a case in the
southwestern united states with girls on
her own
so we thought she was a human
trafficking victim we were sure she was
a human trafficking victim and our
analysts
are really really good yet when
the law enforcement wrapped her up she
was on her own well after questioning
her for about
20 30 minutes she broke down crying and
the human trafficker had her baby
and was threatening to hurt her baby and
had her baby in another city
and that was the handle he was using to
control her
makes sense what a way to hold somebody
hostage
i've not asked you this before but i'm
asking you right now and hopefully you
will do this as a valuetainer please
share this video text it to people hit
the thumbs up button
share it whatever way you can for other
people to see it for the algorithms to
be on our favor because this is not a
message about how you make millions how
you make billions how you become
successful
it's not entertainment this is purely
something that's about education and
awareness i'm asking you
share it with any parent that you know
and say just watch this video
get a paper and pen out you're going to
want to pay attention to this one here
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
you